we're expecting some major economic
indicators this week including the
monthly consumer confidence numbers one
major area of concern right now housing
process housing prices rather which have
you heard have been soaring nationwide
tampa florida has seen the largest bike
in the country nearly 36 percent since
last year that's a huge jump rents are
up about 22 percent from last year mark
straussman shows us how the lack of
affordable housing is hurting residents
it looks like a bungalow as a realtor
kela mccaskill compares tampa's housing
market to a hurricane's aftermath
everything you have on your list of
requirements thousands of people
scrambling for a place to stay all the
way to the fence may not be your first
choice you may be working on your third
or fourth short fourth choice and you're
going to probably make a compromise
somewhere and you're going to make
you're definitely going to make some
compromises tough for buyers worse for
renters like erica belazarian this pr
account exec moved here from albany new
york for cheaper housing a year later
her tampa landlord wants to raise her
rent 530 dollars beyond her budget and
it's just a little unconscionable that
this was allowed to go on and
not do anything about it thousands of
people relocated here throughout the
pandemic add inflation and surging
interest rates and rentals become
unavailable or unaffordable are y'all
going to help me tampa city council is
getting an earful from residents and
realtors like mccaskill we would like to
ask for this crisis to be declared an
emergency tampa city officials recently
put 5 million dollars into a fund for
rental assistance
demand was overwhelming the money gone
in two days that's why to mccaskill this
crisis is at hurricane level multiple
thousands of people are being displaced
every day because they can't find
somewhere to go that alone should say
it's an emergency this one is a three
bedroom town home it is for kavita gwen
your laundry mccaskill showed her this
three bedroom option it's section eight
subsidized housing this is a half bath
now that would be an addition but she
says this backdoor pond is a potential
danger to her autistic son the single
mother of three needs a place by august
first do you have any idea where you're
going to be living no i don't have any
idea but you know every day is really
just a faith walk a faith walk she hopes
will lead to her family's new front door
for cbs mornings mark strassman in tampa